it's no use going back to yesterday
because you were a different person then
imagination is the only weapon in the
war against reality
our world is not Wonderland but after
listening to the quotes of Lewis Carroll
you can be filled with the thoughts of
the great writer and can even get into
the real Wonderland for a moment
everything is funny
if you can laugh at it
if everybody minded their own business
the world would go around a great deal
faster than it does
it is better to be feared than loved
people who don't think shouldn't talk
if you don't know where you are going
any road can take you there
[Music]
sometimes when you're thinking about
someone you love
it makes you forget how to talk
few people find a way out
some don't see it even if they find it
and many don't even look for it
tomorrow is never today
is it possible to wake up in the morning
and say
well
now finally tomorrow
[Music]
one of the deep secrets of life is that
all that is really worth doing
is what we do for others
how long is forever
sometimes it's just one second
[Music]
it would be so nice if something made
sense for a change
[Music]
the best way to explain is to do it
yourself
[Music]
always speak the truth think before you
speak and write it down afterwards
birds of a feather flock together
[Music]
if everything in the world is
meaningless
what prevents you from inventing some
meaning
in the end we only regret the chance we
didn't take
the relationships we were afraid to have
and the decisions we waited too long to
make
[Music]
the best life advice is this
don't live where you don't want to die
[Music]
if you said to work to believe
everything you will tire out the
believing muscles of your mind
and then you'll be so weak you won't be
able to believe the simplest true things
poor is the memory that deals only with
the past
[Music]
if your head is empty
alas the greatest sense of humor will
not save you
you're mad
Bonkers completely off your head
but there is a secret
all the best people are
[Music]
if you want to exude confidence use
statistics
it doesn't matter if they are accurate
or even intelligible
as long as they are enough
you know what the issue is with this
world
everyone wants some magical solution to
their problem
and everyone refuses to believe in magic
that's the reason they're called lessons
because they lessen from day to day
I give myself every good advice
but I very seldom follow it
the things most people want to know
about are usually none of their business
if you limit your actions in life to
things that nobody can possibly find
fault with
you will not do much
better say nothing at all
language is worth a thousand pounds a
word
life
what is it but a dream
in the old days everything was simpler
if you had a lot of money you just dug a
hole and hit it there
it was called opening a bank account
never think that you are different from
what you could be otherwise than being
different in cases where it is
impossible not to be otherwise
one of the most serious losses in a
battle
is the loss of a head
God gave man the right to take the life
of animals for reasonable purposes like
food but he did not give man the right
to hurt other creatures unnecessarily
[Music]
I don't see how someone can ever finish
if that someone doesn't begin
everything's got a moral
if only you can find it
previously it was considered necessary
for an educated person to be able to
write at least competently in their
native language if not elegantly
it is doubtful that this will be
followed in the future
to make a woman constantly think about
you
tell her no
[Music]
if you don't know where you want to go
then it doesn't matter which path you
take
[Music]
praise is bad for any of us unlike love
it would be good if the world were full
of it
I like that my books are loved
and I like to think that the kids love
me for them
but I don't like being praised
the worst thing that can be in a man is
restless avarice
and great cowardice
any branch of science when pursued by
one who has a natural inclination
soon becomes as exciting as sport for
the most passionate Sportsman
or any form of pleasure for the most
refined voluptuary
the proper definition of a man
is an animal that writes letters
and what is the use of a book
without pictures or conversation
[Music]
people are not strange weird off nor
crazy
my reality is just different from yours
an English novelist Lewis Carroll was
best known for his children's fiction
stories he created a real Wonderland and
his quotes are filled with words of
wisdom childhood dreams and surprisingly
adulthood thanks for watching